the biden administration is offering
temporary protection for ukrainian
refugees in the u.s letting them stay up
to 18 months the u.n says more than one
million refugees have fled ukraine in
just one week and that number is growing
fast chris lipsey is in la vie in
western ukraine which is the exit point
for many of those refugees
chris good morning
good morning the front line of the
conflict is out east while the front
line in the refugee crisis is out west
with the president of ukraine warning
vladimir putin wants to lower a new iron
curtain one that would hit the ground
right here
with each passing day of war more than
one hundred thousand ukrainian refugees
are added to the tally streaming into
neighboring countries moldova romania
slovakia hungary latvia and most of all
poland of the 1 million who have already
fled 500 000 of them are children the un
says and yet they are the lucky ones
roughly one million more people remain
internally displaced in a country
gripped by war such as these families at
a shelter in the western city of levive
the question on everyone's mind is
whether to stay in ukraine or to go
this grandmother and mother wish they
knew what was best for little alvina
only one year old
we have democracy says svetlana this is
our country not russia's we don't tell
russia how to live why should they tell
us
what is this conflict done to her future
[Music]
if our country is destroyed what can we
do i do not know she says
ukraine deprived ever more of its youth
and its innocence that's four-year-old
andre exhausted after 20 hours of
sleepless escape his father stayed
behind in their besieged city of harkiv
now it's just him his big brother and
their mom
we heard explosions over our heads at
the train station and all the way on the
train says olga you're aware you may
never return home every day begins with
a text to our relatives says 16 year old
dennis we ask are you alive
more than 2 000 civilians have been
killed ukraine says though the real cost
of war is always more than its death
toll and bravery is to be found beyond
the bullets and the front line
and just bear in mind the sad scenes
we're seeing here are even worse in
besieged cities like mariupol on the
coast where civilians are finding it
harder and harder if not impossible to
flee as russian forces surround them
gail
still so hard to comprehend thank you
very much chris livesay in la vie